boys
america
america america
what's up freedom fighters welcome to
american trash taste baby um freedom
fighter one with freedom this is not
even the right accent for where we're at
we're we're in l.a
we're in l.a joey oh my [ __ ] god guys
welcome back to trash taste the best
show on the [ __ ] internet uh this
this ain't my man's guys this this this
is not our man's right now come on you
are
i am your man
not when you do that what the [ __ ] not
when you do that i had to set the scene
you know because uh we're once again in
a different place yeah entirely we're
not in the uk anymore we're in the
united states of america now but you
truly had like the karen accent you're
truly like now cosplaying you you're
karen form aren't you call the manager
right now i need to speak with her yeah
but uh yeah we're in la in this uh
beautiful airbnb yes the most grandiose
outset has ever looked
these couches are like is it
these couches are pretty [ __ ] nice
okay these couches are comfy i'm a bit
too comfortable because i'm just like
sinking back in i'm definitely singing i
gotta like [ __ ] talk and be aware and
i'm just like jojo you you i'm thinking
about like i have to hold my mic because
it just keeps moving
so i have to do that every podcast ever
[ __ ] with their mic yeah
exactly
one point if i have one second without
touching my mic on a podcast i'll just
double check like
yeah double clutch like ladybird did but
uh yeah we've uh made it to los angeles
um and we've somehow found like been
able to build a studio despite a lot of
issues oh that's we're gonna get into
that very quickly um i'm sure the the
rounds have already
been made of the actual situation yeah
the rounds have already been the rains
people online if you've been on reddit
maybe you're aware of this uh if not
which i'm like a big portion of the
audience isn't uh the subreddit yeah so
our baggage con containing melin said it
was thirty thousand dollars worth of
equipment it's actually i think closer
to fifty thousand yeah
yeah closer to fifty thousand worth
dollars worth of filming equipment all
our mics all our cameras uh were lost
on the way here
and uh at this point at this moment we
still don't know where they are yeah
yeah so we had to like scramble to get
all of this equipment so that we can
actually film some episodes and you know
especially because we're going to get
guests on eventually as well yeah from
next episode yeah so uh
it's just stressful as [ __ ] this was not
the start that we wanted i'm so thankful
that we scheduled in like two three free
days of just like no guess no filming
anything yeah uh because if we if we
thought that we were gonna hit the
ground running we would have been [ __ ]
like i guess literally arrives and it's
like so where's the set like uh
about that yeah it doesn't exist yet do
you want to explain your process of
going to okay
so i was in charge of bringing all of
the equipment
uh to america because these boys flew a
bit early uh so i get to heathrow
airport terminal 2
and i already like already alarm bells
are ringing because i get there and i
want to check in and i can't check in
and i hear one of the operators say oh
no we can't check anyone in right now
because there is a queue downstairs of
about 200 bags and no one can check in
right now so i'm like
that's uh that's that's that's pretty
bad that's that's that's a lot that's
like that's like a bad omen right there
yeah that's worrying yeah so i arrive
you know an hour no two hours before my
flights as like that's what they
recommend so i have to wait an hour just
to check in my backs just checking my
bags right uh and that's true for like
pretty much everyone on the plane so i
check in my bags an hour before our
flight and then i check in my normal
bags and then i have we have two massive
pelican cases containing all of our
filming equipment
and um they look at that and they're
like
we can't check that in here you're gonna
have to go to the oversized luggage like
section i'm like okay i'm like oh no oh
no this is this is this is this is scary
already i'm like my spidey senses were
tingling yeah you know i was like
something is going to go wrong
so i bring over the two pelican cases
over to the oversized luggage uh place
and uh so there's an operator there and
you could tell like this operator just
[ __ ] done he did he he does not give
him you're dealing with this for a few
days yeah yeah yeah he does not give a
[ __ ] at all right
and then he looks at the cases and he's
like all right just just put them put
them on there put them on the conveyor
belt and i'll get it through the system
and then he i put it on the conveyor
belt he presses a button to open a
shutter to get it through the airport
the shutter doesn't open and here he
presses again doesn't open and i'm like
okay uh there's something weird going on
here is this a mouth
like malfunction or something and he
just he sits there he sits down and he
sits there for five minutes doing
nothing doing like like doing nothing
right he just sits there for five
minutes and i'd like even like pretend
to work yeah he just doesn't even
pretend to work he just sits down and
like plays on his phone and then like
while i'm waiting a queue starts to form
behind me first it's like one person
then it's two people then it's three
people and like it it really starts to
build up right and so after about 10
minutes of just sitting down doing
nothing the guy just like tries to press
it again
doesn't work and then he finally he like
phones he like tries to phone somebody
he tries to do something about it
um and so he phones the operator in
charge of whoever is in charge of the
baggage uh and uh he says oh the shutter
won't open and then they say
uh yeah we're not letting any bags in
right now because we are just completely
full like we cannot take any more bags
into our system right and so i was
waiting for about like 20 minutes
uh and so you know i was waiting in this
queue for about 20 minutes before he
presses the button and the shutter
finally opens and like right the [ __ ]
bags finally went through and i remember
by the time my bags went through it was
half an hour before my flight
and like
and like i remember thinking finally the
shutters open bag goes through
and then the shutter closed and there
was just this moment
of
i'm never gonna see them again
like i had i had a feeling i had a
feeling self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
yeah yeah i had like a [ __ ] vision it
closed and i'm just like okay i was like
i have a bad feeling about this like
[ __ ] obi-wan and um i remember
texting the group being like uh guys not
to be alarmed but i'm pretty sure
there's there's a good chance that maybe
we won't get to see our equipment but i
was like hoping out of hope
yeah
and so you know i check in we go through
uh so we i flew air lingus so the air
lingus flight goes from dublin so it
goes from heathrow to dublin and then
dublin to america lax
and so uh the
flight from dublin that's the flight
from heathrow to dublin was actually on
time which i think that's the reason our
bags didn't get delivered because it was
on time and we woke up the next day and
we found out that there's there's an
image on screen with all of the bags
that are like stuck in heathrow terminal
2 now it's like a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
sea of bags right our bag is somewhere
in there at this point
um but then after that
uh i check into my second flight to go
to america
and we all check in i'm sitting in my
seat and then
it's you know you know where you have
some of those flights where for some
reason the plane just doesn't move yeah
right right so i we were sitting there
for like a full-on hour right so like we
were sitting there for a full an hour
trying to figure out what's going on you
know are we actually going to take off
and then after an hour like the operator
comes in and we and was like guys i know
you've been waiting a while uh that's
because there's been a massive queue on
the runway right now uh so we're gonna
be a bit delayed and i'm gonna be real
with you uh it's looking like that we're
gonna be sitting here for another two
hours
so
and like
like you know when like bad news gets
announced and you just feel the air just
drop yeah yeah yeah like like there was
like that [ __ ] grown noise that just
distributed throughout the entire
[ __ ] plane right and everyone's just
like what the [ __ ]
so we we all start getting our phones
and everything like that and uh you know
i
i you know i was thankful because i got
to catch up with [ __ ] spy family you
know
that's what i did with my extra two
hours on the tarmac but after worse yeah
it could be worse but like after being
delayed for three hours on the tarmac
finally i get to go to lax right you
know [ __ ] wow [ __ ] [ __ ]
brilliant i finally i finally get to go
my flight to america the flight itself
was very very pleasant you know um you
know we had some very good
uh
what they called air stewardesses there
you know service yeah service we had
very good service uh the flight itself
was great but then
the nightmare continued when i landed in
lax right
and that's just any landing in lao yeah
yeah yeah the nightmare continues yeah
and so
i get i i get down and i thought that i
had saved time because if you fly from
dublin to america we have pre-clearance
so we don't like if you fly from dublin
you don't actually need to go through
immigration in america that's very
[ __ ] good yeah you can go through
immigration in dublin yeah so it's
treated as a domestic flight so i'm like
great i could just pick my bags and get
the [ __ ] out of there yeah and so i walk
for what feels like 20 minutes to get to
my baggage collection right yeah we all
have to do that yeah yeah yeah yeah and
by the time i get there our bags aren't
even on the carousel because they are so
busy that they are still
like the people from the previous
flights are still getting their bags
from this carousel because there's only
one carousel in the domestic terminal
yeah so we that we like people from
hawaii were still like which was the
flight before we're still waiting for
their bags to come out so we couldn't
get our bags before the
passengers from hawaii could completely
get their bags out so i was waiting for
about an hour
before we even got any of
any bags from our flights to come out
and then
after our after our bags after their
bags finished getting uh collected
finally our bags come out and it's it's
like it's like a drip feed i don't know
how i don't know how it was such a slow
drip feed would like were they like
[ __ ] cycling it over like one bag at
a time because i was like dragging it
over the whole
journey
yeah so
so
it was coming out like [ __ ] five bags
at a time like it's so by the time
by the time like i got some of my bags
out i had i had to wait another like 20
30 minutes and then of course i was
waiting for my equipment bags and then i
wait
i wait a little longer i waited a little
longer and they're all like uh so thank
you ladies and gentlemen uh the air
lingus bag flights uh the air lingus
flight bags are now finished uh so if
you have any bags to collect we've
collected it in the corner and i was
just like [ __ ] i do not i did not see
the bags i had you know i would rather
have lost my clothes than lose the 50
000 yeah of of equipment and so i go to
this corner and there's a line of about
30 people being like where the [ __ ] is
my bag
and and so
after that i have to queue again with
the with these 20 30 people all trying
to like wave their [ __ ] tickets to
like uh like pick a form up and
like it was like my first reminder about
you know what i can experience here in
terms of customer service because i'm
used to japanese customer service
yeah yeah i i'm very blessed with
japanese customer service where they
felt like you know they will do anything
they can to help you or at least they
they will like at least pretend to give
you [ __ ] yeah right yeah like at lax
like i've had two instances now where
there is not even any pretending to give
a [ __ ] about the customer at all like
like if anything i felt guilty for
having to trouble them for an issue with
the [ __ ] airport you know so like i
guess so like i had to like [ __ ]
fight my way through to like give them
the ticket and this guy punching my
numbers in uh to this lost and found
form just could not give a [ __ ]
he could he like
he like he didn't give a [ __ ] so much
that it ended up we found out later that
he'd punched in the wrong numbers
to this form
and so it was like this
it was this experience of everything
that could go wrong with a flight did go
wrong and it turned a already long
travel time from england to america and
added around five to six hours on top of
that as well
i'm so sorry yeah yeah
she's staying here yeah there's like
this they're saying it and uh yeah
that's what that at this moment in time
that's all we know about what's happened
to our bags i think it's still in
heathrow um if i'm gonna guess
yeah
hopefully we can hopefully get our
equipment back like what happens if
they're like oh by the way we delivered
it to lax like a month later and i'm
like we're not in here
yeah yeah yeah i don't know what the
[ __ ] is happening yeah yeah it's just
frustrating it's like i wish they would
tell you anything yeah i think it's the
fact that they don't they like
like the airline leaves you completely
in the dark and doesn't tell you hey
it's here it hasn't been shipped out yet
because it's all backed up yeah okay
well i could somewhat understand that
but when they just [ __ ] tell you
nothing yeah they're like oh no it's an
lax yeah and like like they because
meleen was calling them up and being
very angry yeah good good
good mailing uh
they told meleen that like hey yeah the
bags have been at lax since june 16th
yeah yeah and then he goes to lax again
to try and get there and so i [ __ ] so
they told us that the bags had been
delivered to lax so i was just like i
want to go there physically to pick them
up yeah right because we've got 50 000
of equipment i don't want to risk like
wasting any more time so i drive to lax
and of course driving to lax is a
[ __ ] nightmare in la because you have
to like [ __ ] because you have to
drive in l.a yeah yeah yeah so it takes
us about 40 minutes to get to lax and
then i go to the section where they told
me to pick the bags up
and i had my second experience with uh
lax customer service right which was uh
i
i tried to explain that i have tickets
to pick up my bags um and so the woman
in charge just goes no no we don't have
any bags from air lingus right now and
that's what she says and then she goes
away she doesn't even give me time to
like explain my situation she's just she
just [ __ ] off and i'm like
uh
what could i do
what do i do so like i phoned i found
out male 1 to be like can i get like the
exact details of everything our airline
said to you so i can explain the
situation and so this lady goes off and
i can see her in eyesight she goes off
to the other side of the room and starts
like picking up and messing around with
some bags and so i talked to like one of
the security guards there to be like uh
can i call that lady over please because
i think she's in charge of like the
baggage system here and she literally
like picks out her phone and phones the
lady i can see the lady pick up her
phone and answer it
and she and then and then uh she's like
she's like okay and then hangs up and
then she continues messing around with
the bags i can see her in eyesight i see
her you can literally just run up to her
yeah yeah yeah and so after 20 minutes
of [ __ ] around over there i don't
know what she's doing she reluctantly
comes back looks at me and i can see
like the disappointment in her face be
like why the [ __ ] are you calling me
again right and so i'm like trying to
explain
um yeah i just wanted to get more
information and explain more of the
situation about what i've been told and
what the situation is so i explained
everything that melian has explained to
me i give her the tickets and she does a
[ __ ] eye roll and just
like she literally does that and i'm
like why am i being made to feel guilty
yeah for trying to solve a situation
with my guys creation yeah yeah yeah
it's just
it made it made like a stressful
situation like eve like 10 times more
stressful because like you know i don't
i you know with customer service i don't
mind like if you are not like [ __ ]
japanese level you know
yes king we'll do anything we want for
you you know what you need i'll explain
everything but at least don't make the
customer feel guilty yeah about bringing
up needing a service about needing a
service it just it just made me like she
made me feel guilty for even like trying
to explain the situation and trying to
find out more information
um after driving there for 40 minutes
and she goes in she checks the details
on the [ __ ] luggage tag and
everything and then she comes back and
she's just like there is no bags here
your bags have not been delivered i
don't know what the airline have told
you they've pretty much just said uh
they've pretty much just said something
false because we've had no bags from the
airline at all
and that like that like almost broke me
because that like almost broke me right
because after driving there for 40
minutes not getting my bags after being
delayed for fight like after wasting
five hours of my time the day before
yeah i i now had to drive back from lax
to our studio and
like for some reason god just hated me
on that day because the traffic back was
like way worse than the traffic there so
it took twice the amount of time to
drive back and it was just
ah like i couldn't get it done oh man
like that like that drove my monk
experience to its limit because i was
like i was like up to here i was about
to [ __ ] explode
i'm surprised you didn't explode i think
anyone else would have [ __ ] exploded
long before yeah i was like i would have
certainly exploded internally i was
screaming because like i like i don't
want to scream at like you know i don't
want to be like the karen to like the
customer service manager but like i just
they just situations like that where i
think
it's almost a necessity to be a
character well no because like right
like i didn't want to make i didn't want
to like like bring out my frustration on
the person right but also that person
was i felt bringing out her frustrations
on me right my customer with maybe
previous customers she's had and i'm
just like it just
it was just awful
it was an awful experience there's no
there's no there's no silver lining in
this it was just an awful experience and
it's still not resolved um yeah yeah so
it's it wasn't the best first experience
uh touching touching down in america but
uh yeah come to america wow
welcome to america right what do you
mean you didn't tip your bag handler at
the airport
[ __ ]
you know give him a 20 tip on his salary
to get your bag delivered we [ __ ]
talk about that because that's that's
one frustration i've had since getting
here right so it's like you know
obviously because we had lost our [ __ ]
right and it still hasn't been resolved
we had to figure out ways to get the
equipment right so it's like we're
calling up camera play camera rental
places we're calling up light rental
places yeah all that kind of stuff and
then we realized oh there's no uh mic
stands right because we're usually
attached to a table right but wait like
that's not going to work with you know
the current set we're in right now so
we're like alright [ __ ] we got to buy
some mic stands so i'm like all right
i'll just get some on amazon you know go
on to amazon blah blah blah
and i think again this is where we're
blessed with amazon japan standards yeah
which is it is very rare to get
something on amazon no matter how small
or large how cheap or expensive it is
and usually 99 times out of 100 you'll
get it the next day yeah
next day delivery that's just like
normal yeah
so i thought
it would be the same here yeah they do
have next day delivery if you would like
to pay
500 more
for shipping yeah and like i looked at
it and i was like hold on how does that
work so i get free shipping if it comes
on
like three days from now yeah but if i
want it tomorrow
i basically have to tip amazon
10 15 more yeah to get it the next day
yeah it's about 10 15 delivery uh if you
want to get your stuff the next day yeah
which i'm i'm of we're obviously blessed
with amazon uk amazon japan which it
comes free with prime you get next day
delivery yeah and like you know i like i
would i would understand maybe if uh if
it was kind of like
one thing that surprised me because i
thought you know [ __ ] amazon started
in california right yeah yeah yeah yeah
so so can we fact check that at least
because i i don't know amazon yeah
it was it's uh seattle is this yeah oh
yeah okay okay
it's american yeah okay okay okay just
fine ignore that that's that's that's
just i made it the [ __ ] up moment yeah
yeah okay seattle but i would think that
with la being one of the
the [ __ ] major cities in america
right because like you get perks if you
order from say london in the uk i
thought with la with this being like you
know hollywood and needing a lot of
equipment a lot of shipment and
everything like that i thought that they
would have a service that is more
convenient
um and i yeah i was very surprised to
see that you can't get the same level of
convenience
uh just by being in l.a you literally
have to pay to win yeah it's it's hard
right there's a lot of like uh
socio-economic factors involved right
yeah i mean already right like
next day shipping you don't really need
next-door shipping like when do you how
often do you need next-day shipping all
the time no never normally no i do
because i i usually when i have to buy
something on amazon it's when i need it
urgently yeah and i don't have enough
time to go to the shops to get it or i
or perhaps it's something that i can't
get like an example just give me an
example
well say for example like camera
equipment in japan right isn't that
right it's very rare that you can go to
a big enough like yoda bash your big
camera that has the exact specifics
yeah well you know sometimes there are
some brands for example that you can't
easily access in japanese but like i i'd
say it's very rare that you need 100 you
need this next day like i bet 90 of [ __ ]
you ordered on amazon you did you did
not need that next day i'm sure yeah but
the convenience is there right yeah yeah
it's there i think it's it's good to
have that convenience but i think
especially in america cause it's just
like so inefficient
and like you know everything is
delivered by roads like have you seen
the videos of like the
the
freight trains at the liver stuff in
like california yeah i have to [ __ ]
break it open yeah yeah they get robbed
all the [ __ ] time yeah wow i just
think because the infrastructure just
isn't there and then the next day
delivery that they do do is almost like
it like [ __ ] up the like the people who
have to actually deliver it because they
have to do these insane routes right
trying to deliver this and they're
pissing in bottles and [ __ ] so part of
me is like yeah i love next day delivery
but i feel like just in america it just
doesn't it's not feasible it's not
feasible and if you are doing it
something bad is happening to someone
who is yeah i guess this is definitely
like me being privileged it's definitely
awesome it's definitely pretty much i
just wanted to talk about it because i'm
like yeah it's a complicated thing and
like
yeah
i mean there's a bigger underlying issue
to it you know japan
for some reason people don't give a [ __ ]
about being worked like crazy for like
nine hours and being superficial
i don't know why in the uk you get next
day delivery as well you do but in
london it's it seems like it's it would
make way more sense to have that work in
london but like in wales you don't have
that oh you don't
not really like i lived right next to
the amazon warehouse in swansea and it
was never next day delivery really i
live next to the warehouse right for the
whole area
uh it's just i don't know london it
makes more sense it's possible there's a
lot more like curious is there maybe
like a sense of urgency towards like
fulfilling customer like requests maybe
because like i i assume in wales not a
lot of people are like ordering from
amazon right sure
surely in cardiff right maybe in cardiff
yeah yeah yeah but like i think all the
card afforders are being filled
fulfilled by the swansea yeah right it's
about an hour yeah because like i guess
that's what i thought where i would
understand if you lived like in the
[ __ ] boonies like in the middle of
nowhere okay you're not gonna get to get
next day delivery but like if you live
in america this is l.a yeah this is this
is l.a you can get it but like i it's
only certain items right because it's
got to be fulfilled by amazon which
means it's in their warehouse already
and then they get one of their couriers
to come and get it and that makes more
sense but i don't know the whole [ __ ]
system here is weird and even in europe
it's like not as good as japan japan
yeah works just but japan's had like
like an amazing shipping network for
like forever yeah like they've they've
they've got to figure it out yeah yeah
everything like that's what they care
about yeah that's like there like and
not a single tip was necessary yeah yeah
because people yeah because people here
they're like bro we've got like so many
issues like guns and then japan's like
yeah that if that [ __ ] package
doesn't [ __ ] turn up when i tell it
to i'm not voting for you yeah that's
like legit that's what they give a [ __ ]
about it we've only been here like a few
days and like within that few days we've
just like we can feel like an entire
complaining about america like like this
is just the complaining about america
episode
yeah yeah because it's just this endless
[ __ ] stream because like well care is
like an endless loop of like
dichotomy is like okay oh this big
company does bad thing but it's like the
reason why it's doing bad thing is
because people don't want to do anything
else and yeah it's just [ __ ]
cause
i get it to a point why why i've
experienced such bad customer service
because it's because they have no
[ __ ] incentive to give a [ __ ] about
their job right and you know i get it
you know i've i've especially dealing
with people at the airport you deal with
like the most stressed out people in the
world right you know at you know at a
level i get it you know
um and it's kind of sad in a way where i
see a lot of people in customer service
uh positions and you and it feels like
the only people that you see actually
care about giving a good service is when
there is an option to tip in the
occupation yeah right
it's true yeah i mean i mean that's
that's that's just what i've seen like
if like there is there are plenty of
customer service positions in america
but only the ones that tip i've with my
own experience is the ones where you
really feel that they care about the
customer right right and
society right
we live in a society society
i'd love to say that man yeah dude i
would do different yeah i i would
totally care yeah i don't think i'd care
no no no well no no i'd be like i don't
[ __ ] care like why would i
you know it's on my back well especially
if you're surrounded by that environment
right it's like you'd look like the
weirdo if you're the one that's caring
i'm i'm sure at lax that woman has
probably had the most horrible people
like yeah shouting at her yeah i'm just
screaming and then no repercussions yeah
yeah
the guy [ __ ] walks off goes home he's
like i did nothing wrong yeah you know
you know yeah yeah yeah i i totally get
that it's it sucks though but it does
suck and you're like why don't you on me
i was nice to you yeah yeah yeah but
like it sucks for me because like i
happen to be the person that all that
[ __ ] frustration got taken out of
yeah you know
like it just felt [ __ ] horrible just
not to be given the time of day or just
to be like made to feel guilty for just
trying to like resolve one issue in my
end even in the uk that's pretty rare
yeah they happen often the i feel like
there's a level of disappointment and
resentment that everyone has
it doesn't really yeah yeah it doesn't
really go below that everyone kind of is
just kind of like yeah all right
yeah because i feel like in the uk you
can really just like look i'm going
through a [ __ ] day right
there's a certain tone where you know
especially in this kind of situations
where i feel like it's much rarer in the
uk from what i've seen to like see
people really have like a [ __ ]
outburst you know what i mean i mean
that they were that they're all planning
i've seen playing it will definitely
happen yeah but
it's less than what i've seen you know
here in america at least okay i just i
just needed to vent a bit okay because i
literally like lost about like
encountering about like eight hours of
my time to this i mean like when it's
when it's lax it's like triple it's like
yeah
yeah yeah yeah you you you gave eight
but you lost twenty times yeah yeah i
move slowly i feel like i lost like a
year of my life with this with this
experience you know i mean i'd be
miserable if i worked at lax yeah
miserable going through lax let alone
working out people people are like bro
these are not newark i'm like you're not
[ __ ] any better like what are you on
about like you all suck it's all this is
all broken none of this works
yeah so actually because like this like
because we've been to la before but i
think this is like the first time we've
had like extended stay in l.a right yeah
the longest time i've been in la like in
one goes maybe like five days yeah at
most yeah and that's always been in
downtown yeah right and every time i
talk to a local they're like
downtown really yeah that's like that's
that's like that's like the awful it's
pretty sick yeah that's the sketch
sector
you'll get stabbed or shots uh if you
walk down the streets there which is
something we've definitely come close to
experiencing in downtown l.a around ax
but like the reason we normally come to
la is because of ax and ax is in
downtown l.a so
um so this is actually our first like
experience mostly like outside of
downtown but also getting a chance to
like you know experience actually
explore los angeles yeah yeah so you
guys were like here a few days before me
how was how was your guys's experience
well it was good until i got covered
that's true
i mean it was good for like the first
three or four days because i was staying
in pasadena yeah which is like a
relatively nicer part of l.a everyone in
la says it's a nice part of l.a it was
nice to be fair yeah um and then you
have like you know places like glendale
which is next door which is where all
the youtubers live yeah um and stuff and
like i definitely saw like a more
like relaxed and more i guess like i
felt safer in pasadena and glendale
right a million times more than in
downtown l.a yeah which is not hard
because downtown la is just gta in real
life right so it's like you know i felt
a lot safer and i was like okay i can
actually like kind of walk the streets
of pasadena during the day yeah and it
feels just like a regular town it's like
kind of nice and there's like lots of
places to eat and it's like really chill
yeah um just look like drake and josh
when i realized that yeah
i felt like i was on an episode of drake
and josh a little bit yeah i like walked
past like like an elementary school that
looked like
like it was ripped straight from the
simpsons and i was like oh
like it was like that was like okay you
know that it was that point where i'm
just like okay you know what l.a might
not be as bad yeah and then again there
was just those like just small little
instances
that just made me be like um yeah maybe
not maybe right
yeah like say the [ __ ] lax situation
yeah like you know the amazon situation
it's just like it's it's very nitpicky i
know yeah but i think it just goes to
show how much we've been blessed in
tokyo i mean like it's it's nitpicky but
it's like it's when you choose for like
a place to live for example like place
visiting and living is like two totally
different experiences but like it's it's
a lot of like little things that will
build up over time of course you know
and it's you know one thing i've really
really missed
is walking yeah i've missed walking a
lot and you know i'm sure like there
there are some places in in la which i'm
you know i'm sure you can walk you know
but like i feel like a lot of america as
a whole is just not built for walking
yeah that's all right because i remember
i was i was meeting up with a friend of
mine uh and she she just lives she lives
like kind of uh in the middle between
pasadena and glendale so like from my
hotel it was like
20 minute walk yeah right at most yeah
and so i was like we were hanging in
pasadena we had lunch and [ __ ] and then
i was like oh let's just go back to your
place and we'll just hang out yeah and i
looked on the map and it was like 20
minutes i'm like yeah we can walk that
it's a nice day [ __ ] it's the middle
of the day it's like what 2 p.m yeah
afternoon i kind of want to have a walk
and she was like she looked at me like i
was a [ __ ] weirdo she was like what
are you homeless yeah it's just like
walking what the [ __ ] this is like we're
gonna walk it and i'm like
don't [ __ ] look at me like that like
yes i would like to use my legs because
i haven't done that in a while since i
got here
and uh and she was just like
okay
and you know kind of thing and she kind
of reluctantly followed me yeah um i got
like five minutes into this walk yeah
and i turned a corner and i was like i
don't want to go down there
i was like okay i can see what you were
talking about
yes it's a 20 minute walk but it's also
20 minutes of my life potentially in a
lot of danger at the same time you know
it's 30 minutes when you've got to do
like the navy seals checks and all that
yeah yeah yeah
when you've got to dodge all the
homeless people yeah but it's uh yeah i
don't know even it could be like i felt
i feel weird catching an uber to some
place that's like five minutes away yeah
but it's you have to right living here
and i think that's like one thing that
made me realize
you know perhaps
la is fun to visit but definitely i
wouldn't want to live here yeah
personally speaking i don't know when
there's like four lanes of like cars
it's like crossing it just feels like a
[ __ ] dice roll
and there's like a lot of them don't
have light so i'm like wait so when do i
go it's just like no no you play chicken
you cross the first two yeah and then
you kind of wait in the middle literally
the moment you step out of the car you
are playing with your life
you're just playing frogger
yeah i mean it gets pretty [ __ ] scary
especially like especially when you're
in downtown la or like any like sketch
places right which there are a number of
in l.a no no i'm white
yeah you get a free pass
[Music]
because i [ __ ] i still remember i was
saying this to conor the other day i
still remember that [ __ ] airbnb you
and sydney booked at the last time we
were in uh ax oh yeah and i remember you
sent me you were having like a house
party and you sent me the the address
right on google maps and i was like oh
sick it's like literally just around the
corner from our hotel so i was just like
let's just [ __ ] walk in a three
minute walk right and i remember we were
mostly on the main road you know cars
whizzing by you know a couple of people
on the streets or whatever it's like all
right cool yeah and the moment we got to
your street it was just this dark
alleyway
yeah and i'm like this can't be right
yeah and then from all the way across
the alleyway i could just hear you going
over here
now like you are not making me walk down
this block
are you kidding me yeah there are like
two other people in this alleyway
looking sketch as [ __ ] just like
standing around like i'm literally about
to put my life on the line yeah to go
and hang out with god yeah all right
[ __ ] it let's do it because it was like
i remember that airbnb because inside it
looked [ __ ] fantastic yeah yeah you
know it was great yeah it's not as
[ __ ] fantastic we had like a pool
table and everything like it was it was
a nice open space yeah but my god it was
in like the most sketch area you could
ever imagine and i felt bad whenever
like i was inviting people around to
that airbnb because i know you remember
you like yeah at least like you walked
down that dark alleyway because like our
house was like right at the end of this
dark alleyway and it wasn't it was like
an alleyway with a dead end
so like if you if you would like to rank
like the top places to get mugged in la
i'm like i'm pretty sure that was like
top 10 places to get mugged and stabbed
in l.a
and i remember like
uh i invited super eye patch wolf john
uh to the apartment as well and i
remember he gets the same point right
and and all i see is like a dark
silhouette because he's like he's saying
that he's standing at the end of this
alleyway i see like this dark silhouette
it's john he's by himself and
uh and i'm like i go out i see him like
god oh yeah oh yeah but like i'm sure to
him he just goes
and so like and so i remember he like he
sees my silhouette i remember he starts
walking the opposite direction
immediately starts like power walking
the opposite direction
yeah yeah yeah and so i have to like
[ __ ] sprint to run up to him do we go
john john it's me it's me don't worry
and then he starts running faster he's
like get away
oh yeah that was scary yeah yeah yeah i
remember a long time ago connor you were
saying that you wanted to live in
america
yeah i think it'd be fun for a while has
that has that opinion changed no dude
i'd get so much content living here yeah
but you'd have to well like okay okay
when you say living in america do you
mean living in l.a i don't know about
that yeah
like i just feel like even like you just
talked to an uber driver you're like
great i just got content for like a week
dude
just talking about this guy how crazy
[ __ ] he said to me yeah yeah it's like
it's a crazy place but it's like i don't
know at some point i'd like to
experience it more but because i feel
like even two weeks isn't enough right i
want to experience the awful process of
like signing up for a water bill or
something
why would you want to why would you why
i don't know i love that [ __ ] have you
have you not already experienced it
enough in japan no but yeah i love going
through that mundane stuff about it it's
like i don't know if you really feel
like you're in it i don't know why
something about that experience i really
enjoy yeah i'm good bro during i'm like
this is awful yeah but after the fact
i'm like like i'd love to be like yeah
lax dude what a [ __ ] crazy you know you
know what i mean like people
you know
like being here for a few days we've
already got like a [ __ ] like two
weeks worth of content for trash takes
yeah honestly honestly dude
you got married we didn't speak about
that yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah
i guess i guess like too busy [ __ ]
ranting about america oh yeah i guess
this is the first podcast uh since i got
married so yeah
congrats well i'm i'm i'm a married man
now yeah
yeah so i guess i guess now i can ask
what was okay sex i mean i remember
before the marriage you were just like
oh yeah you know it's it's gonna is it
gonna be the jiu-jitsu kaisen of
marriages it's okay is it gonna be mid
it's gonna be mid you know
how was your guys's experiences with it
it was okay
sherry could never say you know
i couldn't i could have been in my i
could have been in my hotel room
watching jesus christ soon but you know
i had to come out no that was fantastic
i mean like
yeah it was just uh
because i mean this is what like my
second or third
like wedding i've been to yeah is is
this your first like mates wedding you
guys have been to this is my second
baseball it's my first year but it was
very different to my first mates winning
oh because it was the indian wedding no
no it was the japanese wedding oh okay
it was a very traditional like you know
[ __ ]
invite your boss and your colleagues
level japan yeah yeah yeah like actually
this i'd say this was the first time
where it's like a proper like you know
mates when yeah yeah
um i got really [ __ ] close to crying
watching you cry though yeah yeah i
thought because like in my head i was
like in my head i was like okay this is
a really [ __ ] momentous occasion for
god yeah you know obviously every
wedding very emotional yeah yeah really
important day for a lot of people right
and so like you know i'm
like you know i cried at my cousin's
waiting right right because obviously
like watching a family member cry is
gonna make you cry right but i didn't
cry my mates winning yeah right nothing
against my mate yeah i just did it
you're not good enough yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like it's like you don't
deserve it right you're a mate but
you're not my boy yeah yeah yeah but
like so but i was fully expecting that i
was gonna cry at some point in your
wedding yeah but i didn't know what was
going to be the trigger yeah right and
definitely it and the trigger came very
quickly when you started crying
because i don't know because there's
something about
watching god cry that is like
really [ __ ] sad it's like seeing your
dad cry for the first yeah exactly it
just doesn't happen it doesn't happen it
never [ __ ] happens so when you see it
yeah in real life
it's just like oh [ __ ] yeah this is like
this is going to make me cry and like i
i could tell that i wasn't the only one
because literally [ __ ] 70 percent of
that room was crying at that moment it
was like a sniffing convention for a
while
told me man
and then and then i cried and then i
almost cried a second time when we
it was that clip where we hung it out oh
man
so many [ __ ] wholesome moments from
that wedding i'm [ __ ] glad i'm
[ __ ] glad i'm happy i'm happy because
i'm glad that
everyone was it was just like a
happiness like [ __ ] gathering you
know everyone was just like good vibes
everyone was just happy it was good
vibes and that was before everyone got
like [ __ ] hammered and [ __ ] drunk
dude some people got blasted there melin
melen maylin right all right how many
i remember melin so we had we had an
open bar
uh
and i remember the best and worst
decision ever best and worst decision of
my life because i remember going up to
the bar to open the bar and you have to
put like a tab down on the bar
and i remember asking how much should i
you know how much is like a reasonable
number right to uh to to put the tab
down uh and the guy says like you know
we've been doing weddings for years we
recommend this number great and so i was
like great just in case i'm gonna put
double the amount so that i don't have
to like get charged uh so you don't have
to call me if it like breaks that limit
so i'm like great and so how it works is
that however much you don't spend
uh they'll refund you so about like a
few days after the wedding i give them
an email to be like oh great can i get
the refund please how much was not on
was not used on the tab yeah and
i waited a few days because it was like
bank holiday or something and then i get
an email about all this [ __ ]
transactions yeah i get an email back
and i'm like oh great uh we can refund
you at grand total of one pound forty
legit one pound one pound forty damn
and i'm like
damn yeah i'm like i'm not even mad
anymore i'm just impressed you're like
meticulously calculated yeah but it was
like double the recommended amount and
you guys [ __ ] destroyed that and i
i'm not i'm not surprised because like
i've never seen so many [ __ ] shots
being taken out in like one night i'd
say like i'm i took around like seven
shots of tequila that night my god melin
was a [ __ ] tequila fiend my god if
you had become if you
went into like a five meter radius of
melind you are getting dragged to it to
do a shot of tequila i remember like
there's one time i remember seeing melin
like ask joey if she if you wanted the
shot and you're like no no million i
hate shots and she [ __ ] gave you a
[ __ ] death grip yeah and just dragged
me to the bar and made you do a shot she
literally grabbed me by my sleeve and
was just like
no it's not an answer
that's how i did that first shot and i
was like
so okay so the first shot was like all
right you know what it's it's it's a
wedding there's like seven other people
doing the show with me [ __ ] yeah you
know i hate tequila
so much yeah but i'll do it just because
i don't want to you're vibing yeah i'm
good i want to be part of the vibe right
so i did it
it was [ __ ] horrible and then the
second time around was when melian was
like no it's not an answer and gra
dragged me to the bar yeah again with
all the familiar faces like oh the first
time for you all right yeah so i did the
second shot hated it and then a couple
of hours passed by and i'm like okay
alien hasn't called me back yet and so
just when i thought i was in the clear
mailing from a distance [ __ ] scutters
towards me
and it was just like
tequila shot joey and i just had to go
[ __ ] off
i literally i literally flipped a finger
i was just like no
get away from me and and i just walked
off and merely it was just like [ __ ]
run yeah i literally ran from her cause
because i thought because i knew if i
wasn't like stern about it yeah she
would grab me by the slave again yeah
because i heard from a bunch of other
people who were like way too nice to
mainly yeah they were like yeah she made
me do like six shots and i'm like that's
because you have to say the hard no
you have to say it's not just the
softness it's the
yeah predator
yeah did you make you do any shots i
think so i didn't really mind though
one's fine yeah
you only got to do one i think melee
only made me do one what did you make me
do like three just because you were just
too close to her
vicinity-wise yeah yeah so i was really
worried because you know we had food and
i was like this isn't enough there's not
like
three courses gone yeah
i'm a six-course kind of guy minimum or
at least give me someone else's course
who didn't finish right yeah and then
and then lord behold people just start
bringing out pizza yeah we we go or you
could eat pizza it go it was like
all we can eat like stone baked pizzas
yeah i think i had like four whole
pizzas
it was it was
i had a i had a worrying amount of pizza
it was like it was more pizza than any
doctor would ever recommend yeah like
even if you were like carb loading for
like a desert survival for like 10 weeks
you wouldn't eat then this many cows
this was i i don't know every time they
brought it to me i was like well i can't
say no i mean it's a different topic i
gotta try it that was me with the
espresso martinis oh yeah i think i had
like five espresso
and i'm like oh that's why i'm shaking
yeah so we had a station to uh give out
free espresso martinis to everyone wow
yeah
i mean we wanted everyone to have a good
time like oh no wonder that tab was
high but that wasn't even on the tab
that was like a free package that we
paid for i remember i remember i was
like i went up to the bar after like my
first espresso martini that they brought
out for everyone right and i was like oh
can i get another espresso martini and
the dude literally just points to the
side because there's literally this like
three layered shelf of espresso martinis
there was like 12 espresso martinis i
was like take your pick i was like oh
[ __ ] all right cool
well i just drank like three of them and
i was just [ __ ] shaking yeah so i
guess like to go to like the start of my
experience with the wedding because
obviously you guys experience was very
very different from mine yeah
yeah so like um so we had like about i
think it was only like 62 people at this
wedding so it's like a fairly small
wedding but like i really really like
the size of the wedding because it was a
good amount of size i could keep up with
like pretty much you could interact with
everyone i could talk with everyone and
not feel like it was just like a
convention experience where i was having
like one sentence conversation with
people would like have proper meaningful
conversations which is which is good
because i just wanted to like i just
wanted to just like share the good vibes
and everything like that
um but i remember like the night before
the wedding i was so [ __ ] i don't
know i don't know what the right word to
describe it was it was like a mixture of
like nervous and excited because like it
was it was not like the bad kind of
nervous like the way i described it was
it kind of felt like you were 10 years
old and it was the day before christmas
and like you know you knew
you knew you were getting that n64 for
christmas you you knew that this was
like the special christmas when you were
getting the [ __ ] game concert yeah of
course and so i i did not get like i got
like two hours of sleep before my
wedding for the day for my wedding
because i thought because i i tried to
go to sleep at a reasonable time so i
was going to go to sleep at around 11 00
and like i'm like great i'm gonna have a
reasonable amount of sleep before my
wedding can be well rested and then like
an hour passes two hour passes and i'm
like i cannot get to sleep okay okay if
i go to sleep now
i'll get six hours of sleep now
now
an hour passes all right five hours of
sleep now that's how it always works now
and i'll just like if if i if i just go
to sleep now i'll wake up and i'm gonna
have a wife you know it's gonna be break
and then it gets to about four or five
in the morning and i'm like i'm like
trying to i'm like trying to like i'm in
pure copium right now because i'm just
like what if i just have no sleep with
my wedding i can function right if i
just if i just stay up all night i can
function right that's that's something i
can do for like one of the most
important days of my life i can do that
but like before i like truly justify to
myself i'm like okay let's just try
something new so i like
i i take off all of my sheets and take
all my blankets and i put them on the
floor i'm like let's let's try sleeping
on the floor on the hard floor and for
some reason i don't know if it's just
like these like asian jeans or something
where it just felt like i was home again
and i just like immediately conked out
it felt like i was sleeping like a
[ __ ] futon or something i don't know
what it was about sleeping on the floor
but like i just immediately conked out
after like sleeping on like a nice comfy
bed or something um and then yeah like
we we go to the vetting uh the wedding
venue and of course it was i was
not like tense nervous it was like the
feeling of like before you get in you
start a panel or you go on stage or
something yeah it's just like you know
this big thing is coming up but you just
gotta wait around yeah for it to start
that's the worst yeah it's it's i was i
was so i was so [ __ ] jittery
and i know yeah like because i talked to
sydney if she was nervous for the
wedding and she was like her nerves like
ended the moment she woke up because she
was like so busy like before the wedding
started because she had to like go do
her makeup go do her hair and like all
the bridesmaids as well so she was at
the
venue from like 9am oh wow and i didn't
i didn't need to get there until 12 00
12 00
to 12 noon yeah the easy job yeah
and so like that that was just like a
lot of time for just me to like be alone
with my own thoughts and be really
really [ __ ] nervous um
and
and so yeah i was i was really tense
nervous whatever but luckily luckily i
had i had my i had my boys with me i had
my boys were there the lads were there
my hype men you know whether they were
there with me um and i remember i'm like
i remember um
going to the boys um so
to fully explain neither of these two
were my best men uh it's it's okay so
i'm sorry i'm sorry guys and only conor
was a groomsman but like part of the
reason was like it made me realize
how long it's been since i've planned
this wedding because we had we like me
and cindy had planned the wedding
basically like before we had moved to
japan
and yeah and like every like air like
every role or like the entire wedding
party was chosen and everything um yeah
and it was like it was like going the
wedding was going to originally be
before trash tastes even started yeah so
it's like [ __ ] insane that like i've
grown so much closer to these two in
like these past two years where like
when my wedding was planned i like i i
knew joey but we hung out only like a
few times you know and we'd hang out
like a lot but i was like not as close
to you as i am now so so it was like it
was so weird to like
it was so weird to have a wedding that
was planned two years ago where like now
the dynamic is like totally [ __ ]
different and everything i was just
saying like
yeah
so like i remember like we call everyone
in to the main ceremony hall uh so
everyone starts getting their seats
and like i call like i'm like i go out i
go out by myself
and i'm like gone you got this you got
this go on this is you're gonna you're
gonna do a no-tier wedding run there's
going to be zero crying at this wedding
and like i got to myself just to give
myself like a breather and like i'm like
okay i bring out like we have me and
sydney had personal vows so i bring out
my personal vows and i'm like
rehearsing them in my head i'm like okay
you got this this is zero tears we're
not going to cry this morning we got
this you got this i read like the first
sentence and i just like started like
[ __ ] like
my jaw my jaw just starts going
and i'm like oh no oh no this is a bad
sign this is a bad sign and so
while i'm like
while i'm doing this like all of my all
my lads all my groomsmen come out and
they see me and i'm like guys i'm gonna
need some hype around me i'm i'm i'm
gonna need some [ __ ] hype around me
yeah and so
like this was a step this was the moment
where i took a page out of connor's book
i'm like i literally go full monkey mode
right outside the ceremony it works dude
it works i was like i was like
you [ __ ] got this you [ __ ] got
this not realizing that everyone in the
site could you hear me like just [ __ ]
shouting but i i heard you shouting at
something but i i wasn't too sure i was
like
that's good right like people who fear
this the shouting type you offer people
who haven't tried it if you tried it
actually yeah you fully commit to it
yeah it works yeah i mean like that time
it really [ __ ] worked because i had
so much adrenaline in my body yeah that
uh that i needed some way to uh i need i
needed some way to release it yeah and
so i remember getting to the ceremony
room and i'm like okay it's good the
shouting helps i'm like i'm like i'm
like recent on the chatting's help uh i
go to i go to the front i turn around
i look at my mum's face and just
immediately
immediately i'm just like i'm a broken
man again
because like oh just
like my cousin told me this after the
ceremony yeah but he's just like if
there's one thing you definitely should
not do when you're standing up there
waiting is your mom is look at your mom
look at your parents and it's true
i i can understand that yeah let's go
because
it's a feeling i can't describe well
yeah my dad and my mom were like [ __ ]
tearing up and i rarely see them tear up
and it's just
it's just like i don't know like
what did my face look like when i was
waiting up there i gotta know because i
i can do a reenactment of exactly what
you were like you're like
that's what you look like close yeah
that's really accurate it's just like
every now
time they were about to like you know
their song ends yeah yeah they're doing
a medley yeah
the song finishes and then they start
the new one and everyone's talking and
then the moment they finish the song i
was like my god everyone yeah everyone
stops it's starting
and then they start playing the next one
i'm not here to like do a bit like what
do i do i don't know and then seeing you
know again it was like it was seeing you
nervous that made everyone else in the
room nervous right being like oh [ __ ]
this is actually finally happening yeah
right and then the quartet stops for the
final time and then it's like everyone
was like okay it's starting right and
then sydney walks down
and then you immediately start breaking
and then i expected which which i fully
expected right so i'm just like oh here
come the floodgates
okay so it comes and then what stopped
me yeah was the song you guys yeah
i was just like oh my god here we go
and i literally like jan was sitting
next to me and moon was sitting next to
me yeah and we all looked at each other
like that that's god's theme right yeah
yeah so like okay so what made you yeah
that's what i wanted to talk about what
made you choose sydney walked down the
aisle to gutsy's theme yeah and i i
thought
yeah yeah which like i knew it was
coming because like i remember it was
literally the day that miura passed away
right and i remember you know we were
we're at netflix shoot at the day so i
didn't have like properly proper time to
like process that news
and i remember that day i went back home
and i put on gus's theme and i was just
like just like zoning out together this
thing [ __ ] crying
to the news that i just got announced
and
and you know sydney also
cindy was also listening to it just
listening to it
uh seeing me listen to it for hours yeah
and she's just like i [ __ ] [ __ ]
love this song you know yeah because
like it's like to me gus's theme is like
by far like one of one of the greatest
tracks in anime to like to like ever to
like ever be made you know it's it's
such a like a beautiful track and you
know it's unfortunate that it's been
memed a lot nowadays so that's that's
like that's like a lot of that's like
how people perceive guts's theme but
like
i remembered listening to that on that
day that it's just such a beautiful
[ __ ] track gorgeous yeah and i
[ __ ] cried to it so many times and so
i remember sydney goes to me
jokingly she turns to me and she was
like
wouldn't it be funny if we walked down
the aisle to this
and i was just like
yeah that'd be funny
and then we both turned to each other
and and we looked at each other in the
eyes and we're just like but what if
what are you going to do the [ __ ]
default music yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then like we we like we're like would it
be would it be cheesy i thought it would
it would be cheesy and so we let it we
let it sink for a while and like we let
it sit for a few days we let it sit for
a few weeks and then like the longer
the longer like we sat in it the more it
felt like it was just the right idea
because like i [ __ ] knew that i was
going to cry listening to gus's theme
walking like
like i'm sure like people knew we were
going to play gus's theme that would
have taken like the [ __ ] guts this thing
yeah you know i i i wish i knew
beforehand yeah yeah yeah because i feel
like
it was for me it was like the initial
like
really yeah it was like that moment
right it's like wow they're actually
using godzilla's thing right yeah like
there was a split second where i i was
about to start laughing yeah but then i
was like but then again seeing you and
then seeing sydney i was just like nah
this is like this this is the right
choice yeah yeah yeah because it's like
i remember sydney was telling me that
you know before sydney comes out all the
bridesmaids walk out yeah so
if if you are familiar with guts's theme
there's like the intro bit and then
there's like the voice there's the voice
of the guy going
and i remember thinking i see all the
bridesmaids walk out and i'm like
where's sydney where's sydney
and as soon as like the [ __ ]
comes up she's she just appears right
and apparently
behind the scenes like like sydney's
like with her dad waiting to walk out
and her dad's like come on it's time to
go and she's like no i need to wait for
that moment the right moment i need to
wait for that voice
before i appear
oh my god
it was like so incredibly well timed it
was incredibly rewarding i thought it
was just like [ __ ] gorgeous smiling
down on us
but no sydney was like no i'm waiting
for this moment i i am waiting for you
to get one shot yeah i didn't [ __ ]
work yeah like i think that's why i just
immediately started bawling because i
hear i hear that voice like just pop off
and i see sydney emerge i'm just like
this is
it is it's a double whammy it's it's
it's like a [ __ ] beautiful slime i
can't i can't
describe
what i felt at that moment because it
was literally like a scene out of an
anime you know it was just kind of like
it was so like a final episode
yeah yeah yeah like like that moment
that that [ __ ] voice hit she emerges
and i'm
[ __ ]
i'm i'm like i'm like [ __ ] getting
teary-eyed just like [ __ ] thinking
about it but yeah she she walks down uh
we say our vows and we like we [ __ ]
stumble through our [ __ ] house
you guys were tearing up obviously but
like like i think yeah you guys
stumble i say you take pauses but yeah
yeah yeah you took it yeah you took your
time with it okay yeah
you know it's
do you want to talk about the the actual
stumble now okay so
which is the greatest moment of this
wedding so obviously everyone's [ __ ]
sniffing everyone's crying after we've
just finished our vows together like
everyone's everyone's very emotional
everyone's saying it's a very emotional
just good vibes everyone's just happy
and so the registrar comes over and she
starts to say like the official vows
that we need to repeat after her in
order to in order to officialize our
marriage
and then she goes like
and then she goes like
uh she said my name like a few times
before so she knows how to pronounce my
name correctly and everything like that
and then it gets like the final vowels
where she goes most importantly yeah the
and she goes
do you
grant god
[Music]
everyone in the room was like
i did it and that just like all of like
the nervousness and the like
like emotions just like [ __ ]
evaporated the entire room explodes and
like [ __ ] starts like
you only thought it was like a fifa
match
[Music]
it was
like like
it was so [ __ ] perfect that everyone
everybody thought it was scripted
everyone thought it was scripted yeah
and you and everyone was like you made
her say that right yeah
it was a bit it was a bit and i'm just
like no
that just makes it even better oh yeah
and i can't remember what i said after
that happened but i was like yeah
got him got him
she did the thing she did the thing and
i'm like damn are you a trash taste
viewer because you just you just gave us
like a year's worth of content man she's
like this marriage it's different
we don't say that anymore we don't say
that yeah we're gonna bring that back i
just realized we've said that in so
[ __ ] waiting with attitude yeah
yeah i mean that that was that was a
brilliant moment that that was like the
icing on the cake yeah a lot of people
would be pissed off you know if their
name got mispronounced at the at their
wedding but i was just like i was just
like this this just this just like made
the wedding ten times more memorable at
that moment ten times more special and i
guess like yeah as you were saying like
the nerves just immediately like
disappeared yeah yeah yeah the rest of
the night was just good times yeah i i
did
almost [ __ ] up so close to [ __ ] up
and one of the most important moments of
my life because we finish our vows we're
officially well officially we're like
husband and wife yeah and then i go sit
down to sign my marriage papers and my
my
my marriage was a week after mcm right
so
like the previous week i had just been
like signing my [ __ ] i just been
signing like hundreds and hundreds of
prints and everything like that but i
was signing them as gigguk right yeah of
course and like
like my my gingham signature is very
very similar to my real signature but
except it spells out my real name right
yeah
um and so what happens is
[Music]
i sit down to sign my marriage
certificate i put down the g yeah and
then i put down the i
guess
maybe
it's like italian
yeah i thought it's a small line and i
luckily like i stopped myself before
like i go too far but well i like i get
like a fifth of the way to signing
giggup on my marriage certificate
that would have been amazing you could
make the a from the eye right yeah
but luckily i was able to recover from
that before i put down the extra g yeah
but were you like sydney pontiac
yeah i said i nearly made a big mistake
i'm nearly married the wrong person yeah
i'm married gigger says sydney's almost
married to [ __ ] gigger
might as well just put down the [ __ ]
animator
flashback i remember when uh you know
the whole the [ __ ] spiel of uh if
anybody has anything to yeah yeah and
sydney was like don't you [ __ ] dad
everywhere that was good i like that
part yeah yeah yeah because we were
planning beforehand in in the in the the
boys locker room yeah right or not the
locker room but like the changing room
boys
the groomsmen and like all the all the
all the dudes were hanging out
we were like conspired to be like what
if we just like when when the when the
pastor says like you know if anyone
objects to this wedding please you know
say your piece right now whatever we
were all planning like all the boys to
just stand up and be like we have jets
and then we just skip
out
like with the boys yeah we're like that
would have been funny yeah but but then
cindy was just like don't you [ __ ]
[ __ ] she verbally said that well i
never
it was a great time and then yeah i just
it just felt like after that everyone
was just on such a high like it already
felt like everyone was drunk you know
but just drunk on happiness drunken like
good vibes and then i'll go yeah and
then no
they're like doubly drunk on top of that
so like they're they're like i mean
there was there was a lot of magical
things that happened at the wedding i
remember so we were taking we had some
[ __ ] excellent photographers and
videographers you know they were great
yeah they were [ __ ] great and then i
remember we we went outside we started
taking like photos and everything uh you
know with like the group photos family
photos and everything like that
and then
um and then we finally have like a
moment to ourselves and joey turns to me
and he goes wouldn't it be funny if we
did like the end of ava congratulations
scene right now and i i looked at you i
looked at joey and i look around and i'm
just i just realized this is like a once
in a
this is literally a once in a lifetime
opportunity i'm like joey that's a great
[ __ ] idea and and i i literally like
we're all weebs here yeah yeah yeah i
literally gather the boys because
you're like that's
it was really funny because before that
because we we had like separate uh well
while we were taking photos like we
we we had you know separate photos like
the guys and like the girls and oh my
god like the guys
the guys had so much [ __ ]
testosterone when we when we took our
photos i can't wait to see them but i
remember there was this really funny
moment where it was like a school
playground again where like all of the
girls were on one side of the venue and
all of the guys were on the other side
of the venue so it was
it was like a school trip or something
so luckily all of the guys were gathered
in one spot and i like i like i like
gather the boys i like i it's it's it's
such a boy yeah yeah i'm like boys
boys come here you're like laughs
have we have an important mission lads
okay and at this point people people are
like people like gum why are you calling
us we're just taking the photos yeah and
like and i'm like
has everyone seen evangelion and
immediately as soon as i say that
everyone's like
king we know what to do say no more
say no walking we know exactly what to
do which is the beauty of like having
like a bunch of like weebs as friends
right because everyone's just on the
same page yeah i didn't even
need to say what we did yeah and so we
filmed the uh congratulations scene
that's [ __ ] amazing it came out
amazing yeah yeah it came out
you did it
wasn't [ __ ] amazing
thank you
[Music]
yeah so like i guess
like going off that that same vein
um like you know we tried to have like a
traditional wedding you know it was
that's true we tried we we tried
yeah it's because but like also like
we're like a bunch of weebs so like
it was even though it was like [ __ ]
painful to have this wedding be delayed
for two years it actually i think came
out to be like a blessing in disguise
yeah because it really really gave me
and sydney the time to really like
yeah to really like add a lot of like
little things like that would just like
us you know
um and like i i feel like that's the
thing that you know people hopefully
really remember that when when they like
think back to our wedding um because we
wanted to have like some
anime references at about our wedding of
course of course we did um but we didn't
want to have to we didn't want like a
full-on [ __ ] cosplay you know winning
which we don't want like a full-on weeb
waiting yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
ultramark could be sebastian mccabe
and so like we we tried we tried you
know we gave uh we gave everyone like a
postcard with like a drawing of either
like it was me and sydney in a wedding
dress in like the end of ava end screen
yeah uh or or it was like the famous rmo
one and i can't remember which one you
guys got i got the ava one oh you got
the everyone i got the
i don't remember that
ava oh you guys got the lucky one
why is that lucky i don't know because i
was i had a bunch of people coming to me
to be like i you gave me the [ __ ] rmo
one yeah really d got
yeah but like we tried to write a nice
little personal message to everyone who
attended our wedding and it's like
little touches like this i don't think
we would have been able to do one if we
didn't have enough time and two
if there was like too many people there
yeah your sister yours was nice sydney
just insulted me yeah yeah i was like
what the [ __ ] sydney
that's pretty much the same with
everyone what the [ __ ]
what did i do i turned up didn't i
actually but like another thing is we
wanted to like try to integrate like the
places we'd been to and the cultures we
were we lived in as much as possible so
we had like uh
uh we had a custom-made muscle box made
which if you don't know what that is
it's uh one of those sake boxes yeah
right so we had like a custom crest that
we
we made which was like a combination of
like both of our families and then we
gave everyone mastery boxes which you
normally drink sake out of yeah um but
so i was excited yeah yeah yeah so i was
like i was like telling everyone at the
table being like yeah so this is this
thing called like
that you use these masu boxes for when
you like you pour it so much that it
overflows into the box and everyone was
like oh cool
and then
and then like if if you know me in
sydney you know that we are not saki
drinkers right yeah but like i don't
know why but there is a drink within our
group which which we are like really
famous for drinking uh because every
time we go to like a party someone
brings like crates and crates of this
stuff and so i announce in my speech
that we're not gonna be toasting with
champagne but we're gonna be toasting
with soju and i'd heard from like
several people that joey was just joey's
face was just like i can't how dare you
i was like i
i've never experienced racism at a
wedding
but i felt like my culture was extremely
appropriate
am i really
i didn't even like soldiers
i did it for you
surprised the cultural appropriation
yeah i had several people being like
dude bro joey is pissed well you said
that okay
pissed is like a strong no no no i know
i know yeah like i was i was like yeah
[ __ ] whatever i was too much on like
a happy hive to give a [ __ ] it was like
the next day where i thought about it i
was like those [ __ ]
how dare you i'm gonna take this muscle
box home just because yeah god damn it
sake just tastes like [ __ ] food vodka
i don't know i mean like you guys just
haven't had the good [ __ ] i did i did
the 100 tasting sake thing it did all of
them happen to taste like [ __ ] yeah
you don't have the power for it
a powder what like a [ __ ] wood chip
not japanese enough i think so exactly
like fire shield yeah sake oh i used to
not like sake like i used to think it
was like paint thinner maybe maybe when
i get older maybe yeah maybe
maybe i'll just have a living yeah
yeah you never know ask me in two years
will i like sake yeah maybe i've lived
in japan for long enough yeah i like i
think like the next thing i remember uh
was actually like the cake cutting so oh
yeah i don't i don't know what you guys
remember but like i'm trying to like
think back to all like the big [ __ ]
things that i remember about the wedding
and
so so obviously it's traditional for a
wedding that you have like a cake
cutting with the bride and groom and
everyone like gathers around and like
take pictures and everything like that
and
uh and i remember like sydney
like cindy cuts the cake and then honor
like her second slice she's like
completely like [ __ ] up and just goes
like diagonal
and
i like it there's pictures of this and i
like [ __ ] burst out loud bus burst
out laughing saying cindy what the [ __ ]
is that but then like she she she like
full-on just like grabs the slice with
her hand like shoves it in my face and
i'm like i'm like i'm like eating it and
then she like she like has a bite for
herself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and obviously like everyone's laughing
everyone's applauding and everything and
then
i turn over to maelyn and i see melin's
mouth moving and she says
and i'm just like what and i i think you
know i think you know oh she must be
saying oh your size is so cute or
something congratulations i hear i i go
closer to be like mainly what'd you say
and she goes lick it lick her
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] freaked
and i'm like what the [ __ ]
but i'm like
okay i'm fine i'll do it for you melin
i'll do it for you
well she was just like
weird
so you just did like a bucharani on him
basically i i licked i licked the rest
of the cake off of him you guys got a
half cake half makeup
she's got a mouth full of makeup
yeah she was caked with makeup
basically in multiple ways yeah yeah i
would like i've heard like some funny
stories about other people that uh
other things that have happened around
the wedding that i wasn't involved in
obviously everyone was drunk uh i think
one of the people who got drunk the
fastest actually was karen
did you guys see karen at all demon dice
yeah
i i was the one that noticed that she
was like slouched on the couch like just
just forward slouched like this yeah and
i i walked up to her because no one was
there and i was like karen are you okay
and then she just turns me she's like i
[ __ ] up man
i [ __ ] up man i was like what happened
like like like what did you get in a
fight or something like what happened
she was like no i thought i had
four
double shots of whiskey
before the food and i was like
why did you do that
just good vibes
oh yeah because i guess she was just
having a really good time yeah i showed
it out my my bedroom was on like the
third floor no elevator i [ __ ]
sobered the [ __ ] every time i had to go
get some from my room i came back down
like fully
[ __ ] walking those stairs
[ __ ] dude yeah yeah yeah is it my
luggage like [ __ ] my entire life
yeah so so i you know so i was kind of
comforting her getting her water and
[ __ ] and then sydney and uh and a bunch
of other girls came to be like all right
you know what you can just like go crash
in sydney's room yeah so that was okay
yeah the other one that was hilarious
was jan
yeah
because he wasn't [ __ ] there
like it was like i was talking i was
literally talking to me it was me and
marky and jan and we were just chatting
and it was like 30 minutes before the
dinner yeah all right and then jan was
like
dude i'm gonna get a nap and i'm like
jan the the dinner's in like literally
30 minutes like we're about to go in to
sit down and he's like oh no no don't
worry i'll be back i'll be back bro
don't worry
and we never saw him again
man went for cigarettes and never came
back it was like the dad going for milk
and cigarettes i was just like yeah i'll
be back and then it was like 10 p.m when
i noticed like i i came out of my
drunken stupor and i was like
yeah
has anyone seen chad yeah i called him i
was like what the [ __ ] are you because
he also yeah but right when he's about
to leave he i was like where are you
going he said i'm gonna go sleep and
like dude dinner right yeah like come
it's right now yeah yeah and he was just
like no no no i'll be back i'm like
you're not gonna [ __ ] be back i know
you're not you're not gonna be back
eat the [ __ ] i was like at least eat the
dinner and then go now they paid for the
food eat the food and then yeah and that
was literally the last time i saw him
until now and like i i texted him i
think like on the day i was about to fly
out like to la because i just remembered
i was like yeah yeah that was literally
the last time i saw and talked to jan so
i texted him being like are you alive
yeah that is that is one question i've
asked jan more than any other person i
know in my life he just disappears yeah
he just disappears and you just don't
know where he is so he's like oh you're
a wife
yeah and he was like yeah bro yeah you
were telling me about how you saw jan in
like the most jan place before the
before the wedding started right so it
was before the wedding started and uh
and it was connor
myself
and i forgot who else someone else i was
mood on i think yeah uh and we were just
like let's just go get like uh because
you know dinner wasn't until like 4 p.m
right and we had gathered at like midday
so we're like well [ __ ] i'm gonna be
starving throughout this reception right
so i was just like yeah let's just
there's a cafe around the corner let's
just go there
and i was walking there and i walked and
we walked past this this alleyway yeah
right
and
i literally did a double take i was like
like that because
jan is standing there
full suit sunglasses with a cigarette in
his hand just talking to a homeless dude
and i knew and he was like and it was
like the most scruffy homeless dude he's
wearing like this red bathroom with like
the cigarette in his hands i don't know
if he was homeless you just dressed like
a [ __ ] um what's uh daniel radcliffe
in the guns of kimber
without the guns
like today you mean the one way is like
yeah yeah yeah they're already that
literally that outfit like one for once
it was like without the hands yeah just
like no shoes bathrobe just with a
little nappy hair with a cigarette in
his hand and jan's just like properly
dressed up in sunglasses with a
cigarette and i'm just like jan and he
looks over and he's like bro help me
i'm like what do you mean he'd help you
and he's like and because he's like he's
like oh sorry my friend's here and then
he walks over to me and i'm like what do
you know that guy and he's like no
and i'm like why were you there and he's
like because he asked for a cigarette
and i saw i just gave him a cigarette
and then he just started talking to me
and i couldn't leave and i'm like what
do you mean you can you could very
easily leave you could just be like
sorry i have somewhere to go but because
of course jan's just too [ __ ] nice
and nice just tries to sweet talk
everywhere he's like he's like speech
100 yeah every time right so he's just
like yeah he's like oh thanks for saving
me bro and i'm like yeah i literally did
nothing i just walked past that you were
talking to a dude in a bathroom it's the
most jan thing i've ever seen in my life
oh my god yeah like another thing that
[ __ ] cracked me up as well was like
because moon on flew in from estonia
just to basically come to come to this
wedding yeah i felt so bad we were like
this was like before like the world like
the ceremony we were all getting ready
in like the boys powder room and then
mudon comes in and then connor's like
mood on i got something for you
he reaches into his bag and brings out
the hard disk
of the previous trash taste episodes
that we had just filmed in england yeah
so i i i didn't just spring this on him
i wasn't like that so we recorded the
teresa's episode ones in the uk right
but obviously in the uk and the us like
these episodes are normally about 400
gigabytes total yeah and like we've been
blessed by japanese there's just no
internet speeds that can do it so it was
either we ship it to him uh to like in
estonia which would probably it would
actually be faster than f trying to find
somewhere to upload yeah yeah yeah so he
was coming to the wedding i messaged him
like hey uh i know this is like kind of
like weird but can i just give you the
ssd of the episodes in person and he was
like yeah sure
but then obviously he was kind of
playing it up in person he was like wow
really making me work
come on
thank you for coming all the way to
england here's some work yeah
he specifically said i'm going to bill
you for this hour
he's like i was like
all right okay
whatever hey but it all turned out okay
yeah yeah you guys got the episode on
time and that's because moon got the
work at my wedding
yeah and like like to build on like the
karen story because you saw like the
girls like
you go you saw like the girls like dr
like
carrying her off to her yeah yeah
um so sydney told me what happened after
they started carrying her off so i told
you the story about my mum at like
my cousin's previous wedding right where
like i've no i never have never seen my
my mom drunk before but like i saw like
a sleeping dragon like awakened at my
cousin's wedding
i saw that sleeping dragon awaken even
harder this time right
because apparently what happened was
sydney was like trying to like help
karen up to her room she feels a tap on
the shoulder
turns around it's my mom
and she has a beer in hand and she says
she's like trying to be polite being
like oh mama are you doing okay i'm
trying i'm trying to get my friend up to
a room like camera's like yeah i
constantly on sydney's shoulder my mom's
like my mom's like watch this
and she downs the bottle of beer
like she doesn't even like say do you
want me to down this yeah this time she
just goes watch this and she goes she
downs it walks away yeah i said he's
like mommy i'm kind of busy right now
and she and my mom looks like karen and
my mom looks back in sydney and she goes
i'll be back wait here
and apparently she goes she tries to go
back to do it again i said he's like mom
i really need to take my friend up to
like my room right now
yeah this time my mom didn't even make
it to the end of the night was popping
off yeah yeah she was popping up you
were popping off on the [ __ ] dance
floor holy [ __ ] [ __ ] joke i was with
dee
and you know and he can dance his ass
off yeah and i heard the cargo summer
opening and i was like i have to pop
there's people that played
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah because like the dance
floor was kind of weird because it was
like there was either no one there or
everyone was there yeah there was no
in-between so it was during the time
where it was like me dean like a couple
of other people and we just you know
there's like a couple of tracks playing
and then and then the calgary summer
theme starts and we're just like
well we gotta dance to this all right
like we're gonna pop off to this one
yeah yeah yeah and so i just stopped
popping off because i was stupidly drunk
not realizing someone is behind me
filming this entire ordeal right yeah
and so when i received the video i was
like
wow i'm [ __ ] right now
i'm so [ __ ] because i never danced
yeah right because i can't dance for
[ __ ] yeah i was i was dancing like my
life was [ __ ] depending on it yeah
and then you went again when uh dev
manoj started playing again i started
playing i was like all right all right
ty is coming off i'm popping off today
[Music]
yeah because i remember we went in waves
because everyone went on the dance floor
and then everyone was like let's get a
drink and then everyone immediately went
to the bar and it just it just kept
coming in waves but i remember like the
the time when everyone started to pop
off was when [ __ ] september played
[Music]
and that's and that's when that's when
the video like me and joey [ __ ]
hugging yeah um came about but like i
remember before that i remember i like
gave conor that conor the hug as well
because
because it was like [ __ ] september
and everyone was so hyped and i was that
was like i think like the hyper song i
don't know why it was september
because i like because i thought it was
just like it's a happy song and also
like every time we used to go to karaoke
together yeah that song was always the
best oh yeah yeah yeah so that's where i
thought it was yeah yeah yeah yeah but
like i would say like if okay so one of
i think one of the best decisions i made
with my wedding if you are whatever
planning advice
here's some wedding advice um if you're
ever planning uh if you're planning a
future wedding or something so like even
though there was only 62 people at my
wedding which is a fairly small wedding
in my eyes smaller yeah yeah smaller
wedding like wedding fomo is a [ __ ]
thing because
i wanted to be with everyone at all
times i wanted to see what was [ __ ]
popping off what people were talking
about i just wanted to see what's going
on because like because there's only one
of me and because there's like only so
much so many hours in this one [ __ ]
day you can only be at one place at a
time and it's like i had so many regrets
um because we're also like really really
[ __ ] busy with the photographers
getting like our own wedding photos or
something like one thing i big one
probably my biggest figure of the
wedding is that i didn't see everyone's
reaction to the postcards and all the
messages and stuff because we were like
should have all filmed your reaction so
i can react to it later yeah
so because we were outside taking
wedding photography uh when you guys
were in so like
one of the best decisions i made is that
i had we had like a gopro there
uh because of course we did i learned
from trash tastes right i i learned from
trash taste of course and i was just i
went to like everyone and i was just
like film whatever you want just just
just film whatever you want
um and
like i've seen the footage and i'm just
like it's
it gives you like such an on the ground
experience to what everyone was doing
and like we haven't we had videographers
there and so i'm very very excited to
see what they captured on their end but
i think it's just like it was like it
was a totally different view when you
just had people filming their own povs
on gopros right um because like you got
to see like the progression everyone was
like so well spoken so happy at the
beginning of the wedding
and then you go to like the end footage
yeah
it was like a guy [ __ ] kind of so
[ __ ] happy for you
and yeah it was like it was like it was
like one of the best decisions i think
regarding my wedding because i got to
see so much my wedding that i wouldn't
have got to see if uh
if if i did if i didn't have a gopro
there so yeah
no
unfortunately you guys are never going
to see that uh but uh it does it does
exist on my hard drive oh yeah yeah but
yeah like i said fantastic day you know
i know it's a cliche to say like you
know your wedding's like the happiest
day of your life but it was it was top
three
like no one's that jaded where they're
like yeah my wedding was all right yeah
yeah like of course i mean i live it up
yeah i mean like
because like before the wedding i was
just like you know maybe it'll be the
happiest day of my life you know it's i
didn't really think about it too much
we're looking back it was genuinely the
happiest day of my life so far so i'm
glad i'm glad i got i'm glad you guys
got to share that you know yeah it's
[ __ ] awesome yeah i think that's the
best thing about having a wedding to me
like we we had a lot of mates there and
it was just having your mates around to
experience like the happiest moment of
your life is something that i cannot put
into words it's just it's it's it's so
[ __ ] special yeah absolutely and joey
wore trainers
oh yeah oh you're going to talk about
that
joey joey got the vessies on i do okay
so
you know because the wedding was not
done in london it was done just outside
of london right yeah so we were in
london you know for about a week i was
hanging out with a bunch of people what
not and i i had forgotten because
because uh originally i was supposed to
get a suit from the suit rental place
that gone had organized yeah but because
right now in the uk and just i guess
everywhere in the world it's like
wedding craze right now because you know
we're approaching the end of the
pandemic um
they were all booked up right so gant
messaged me like a few days before i was
about to fly out to uk being like hey so
sorry but i wasn't able to get your suit
rental yeah so you're gonna have to
bring your own suit yeah and i was like
okay
i only have a jojo suit i mean that's
fine that's sort of which was okay so i
was like whatever you know i'll just get
that dry clean you know where whatever
but then when i got to london and i was
sorting out my luggage i was like [ __ ] i
forgot to
bring my suit shoes yeah right and so in
the back of my head i was like well i'm
in london for like an entire week i'll
just like pop over to a shoe store and
buy some nice shoes right yeah
uh i got a little bit ham in london
i was like drinking every day in london
right because of course you do yep you
know meeting up catching up with a bunch
of people so
the morning of the wedding yeah as i was
taking my suit out i realized i don't
have suit shoes
and the only pair of shoes i had were
the vessies that i was wearing
so i rocked up to the wedding
in full suit you know type in belt
everything yeah and a pair of vessies
yeah and uh everyone at the wedding was
giving me [ __ ] they were like they
literally
they were literally doing the water
you know fully deserved mind you but um
but you know what at the end of the day
i won because when i got onto that
[ __ ] dance floor dude i was fully
prepared
i was fully prepared with my everyone
like had taken their shoes off to dance
i was like step aside i got the footwear
for you yeah yeah yeah yeah so that was
uh don't do that
bring bring it bring bring proper sushi
i had one job to buy sutures and i did
not fulfill it making it making a
statement there making a statement
exactly i was making a statement yeah
yeah but i guess like you know wedding
aside it was like i guess it was like
a
reasonable amount of time in the uk you
i feel like you got to experience more
of the uk this time as well yeah
absolutely yeah i mean last time i was
in the uk which was the first time was
we were staying mostly at your place in
brighton yeah so i think we were only in
london for maybe like
two days yeah even then it was mostly
just like going to all of the you know
touristy places yeah right so i think
yeah this time around not only did i get
to have like a proper
like view of london london yeah but also
like
chris took me out of london as well to
like we went filming into a bunch of
places and i actually got to see like
the countryside of london i got to see
stonehenge oh did you actually yeah we
went to stone edge it's really
disappointing isn't it yeah
it looks way cooler from a disney yeah
because you actually get so to get to
stonehenge you have to like go to this
visitor's center buy a ticket for some
[ __ ] reason yeah and then you can
either take a bus
which is like five minutes to stonehenge
or you can walk across the fields for
like 30 minutes yeah and i was like well
it's kind of a nice day let's just like
walk across the fields because it might
be nice yeah it was not nice
because it was not only nothing for 30
minutes but there was also just horse
[ __ ] everywhere
so i'm like [ __ ] dodging these like
you know these [ __ ] horse this horse
[ __ ] because god forbid these are the
only pair of [ __ ] shoes i have as
well so i don't want your besties i was
wearing the besties
no i have to wear these things
so we got to it and then i guess because
there was like an incident uh some years
ago of like some drawing you know uh you
know [ __ ] on the stone hair stones
yeah so they had actually like fenced it
off yeah but like they had fenced it off
not really like an arms reach away but
like at least about a hundred meters
away yeah so the closest you could get
to stonehenge was like 100 meters away
which
was kind of like defeating the purpose i
guess like because apparently you used
to be able to like actually walk into
stonehenge and like actually get like a
close view of it you can't do that
anymore because i guess some people just
ruined it for everyone so
which you know was like kind of
underwhelming i guess in a sense but
like you know i was like well you know
stonehenge is like that one uh heritage
site that you hear people talking about
and it's like a hot tourist place so i'm
just like well you know what at least
now i can say that i've seen stonehenge
but like
it was
fascinating it necessarily not really
i'd go to a greg's any day over
stonehenge yeah i mean we did afterwards
we went to greg's afters but like i
think the most enjoyment i had like on
that trip out of london was the fact
that like i just actually got to see
like the real side of the uk like the
actual like country side like we went
past like all these like really small
like quaint little villages that you
like there were some villages that we
drove past that legitimately looked like
rpgs
it was it was like an rpg like medieval
town
which was like so [ __ ] cool most of
the uk right but like i had never seen
that before right because my experience
of the uk is london and brighton right
which is very much not like that yeah so
it was really cool to actually like stop
by in like these really small quaint
villages to be like oh we got like the
full experience of the uk what are the
best one of the best [ __ ] stories
was we stopped by uh i had i was like
dying for a piss right right and so i
was like we have to stop by somewhere
right yeah and but like we're in the
middle of nowhere right so we're like oh
okay i guess we'll just like stop by the
closest village to see if there's like
an establishment right we can borrow um
so we stopped by this village i don't
even remember the name of this village
it's [ __ ] tiny and
we got to the entrance of the village
and there's like this old dude standing
there and he like kind of flags us down
like hey yeah and so chris is like all
right this uh what what's what's
happening and we drive up to him and
he's like yeah what's what's the problem
and the guy goes are you here to see the
duck race
and we're like what
it's like there's a duck race happening
so make sure to drive nice and slowly
across this road okay
a dark race
and sure enough we dr we drive maybe
about 50 meters and there's just this
gathering of about
10 to 20 like old people just watching
these ducks
that sounds awesome and i'm like this is
the most british thing i've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life what else are you going
to do with your free time yeah yeah and
i was like i want to be there yeah
at that age i want to just like wake up
in the morning and be like oh the duck
races today and just go down to my local
pond
and just watch some ducks
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah
it's cause like
i remember like as like we went to a pub
the day for a wedding yeah um and it was
like it's very very quaint local pub uh
in this very very small town yeah um
because this this like where the wedding
took place it was in a town that was
like you know you could walk from one
end to the other in about like 30
minutes
it was a [ __ ] tiny so it was like a
local pub and like i remember there was
just this poster on the wall that just
said uh this is the place for the uh the
worldwide annual pea tossing tournament
or something like that oh yeah well it
was the p flicking tournament right well
i think it's the way that the streets
had kind of uh the way like that natural
landscape was yeah the idea was that you
threw at the peak because i googled it i
was curious you're gonna throw the p i
mean this is gonna tell him wherever
your wedding is by the way it's only in
this place i mean i mean
i already have one wedding yeah yeah
so so the way that this kind of town is
really cool architecture it's like kind
of like there's a village at the top and
then it kind of winds down towards the
bottom so the idea of this pea throwing
thing apparently according to google is
it the idea is that you throw it and
hopefully if you throw it well enough or
kind of lucky it'll kind of bounce
around the walls and kind of go all the
way down oh my people will like follow
it and and makes and see where it like
right
it goes which i think that sounds pretty
[ __ ] fun that sounds [ __ ] fun it's
also extremely brilliant that's really
british but that's fun yeah this video
is sponsored by bookwalker guys are you
craving some good manga to get you
through the summer heat yeah i am well
thankfully book walker has got you
covered as one of the most popular ebook
stores for english manga and light
novels out there this summer they're
holding an irresistible promotion where
you can get manga wait for it for free
for a limited time of four weeks
bookwalker now has the first volume of a
different set of market titles available
on rotation for free every week god tell
the lovely audience what's on this week
this week they have some banger titles
such as rent a girlfriend the timer got
reincarnated as a slime but also to
celebrate the beginning of the new anime
season they have the source material to
the brand new anime series called the
yakuza's guide to babysitting which is
airing right now the first volume of
these three titles will be available for
free until july 14th pt but if these
aren't your gem don't fret there are
plenty more coming up in the next few
weeks as you can see on screen right now
so go check out the details of this
promotion on their special landing page
linked in the description below and add
some new favorites to your manga
collection before this promotion ends on
july the 28th pt thank you again book
walker back to the episode so uh you met
my parents for the first time oh yeah
that was fun and uh yeah connor came
around to my house uh a few days before
the wedding we had like a nice meal
together
um and
connor connor met my parents
for the first time i got out of the car
and i was wearing a hat and i met your
dad and i was like oh hi hi and he's
like oh hi hi i go inside and then your
mum sees me oh my god it's connor
she was like i watch you all the time i
was like oh
oh yeah hell yeah
she was just like really sweet and she
gave me a hug and she was like oh my god
i i always watch you on the tv it's so
nice you know it's
so awesome it's really wholesome yeah
and then she like whipped up like the
best food i'd ever had yeah just amazing
it was really good food yeah but there
was there was one moment well i can't
remember if it was when uh when when
uh when she first met you or when you
were having food or something
but i remember she was like talking to
you and then she's like not she's like
never really mentioned to me about like
any of our content aside from like what
we've talked about and everything like
that yeah
so so she's like never mentioned this to
me before but like i remember she turns
to connor and she's like
you should have won the cycling special
and i'm like what the [ __ ] mom everyone
knows that everyone knows [ __ ] i was
like i got betrayed by my own [ __ ]
family i was
i was like she's never ever mentioned
the cycling special for me before at all
aside from like oh it looks like a
really beautiful place you guys were too
but no like i was like i was like
[ __ ] i like glad to know where your
mom's your mom is your mom is literally
the embodiment embodiment of the
subreddit yeah
bro i got [ __ ] betrayed man by my own
blood and then i think your dad then
realized who i was yeah because he'd
said hi to me but he didn't and then i
think when your mom had said that he was
like oh it's oh he's that guy
oh it's connor it's connor hi hi and i
was like oh okay
all right okay
it was really nice it was very sweet
yeah how was your experience back in
england because yeah it was kid i mean
it's it's it's like you know you know
how it's it's like going back
hey i'm back
let's do it yeah uh it was weird seeing
some things had changed kind of a little
bit like uh i don't know it was uh it
was interesting this time because it was
very like full on this time yeah every
single day there was something happening
yeah but that was good i like that
because i kind of hate it when i'm like
kind of like not doing anything and i'm
like just wandering around yeah what am
i gonna do today what am i gonna eat
because what am i gonna eat is so
important
yeah like i was actually like really
much happier with like the food that i
had there like that was so [ __ ] good
yeah i don't know if like the food
quality just improved or we just went to
like better restaurants i don't know i
felt felt like there were more food
options
in my trip back to england this time
right i mean just go to borough market
in london best [ __ ] food in london
yes
every restaurant there goes
unequivocally hard yeah
i spent like an afternoon in the borough
markets with a friend of mine from high
school and it was [ __ ] awesome yeah
so cool dude the cheese there yeah
good [ __ ] dude yeah yeah did an irl
stream in london as well oh you did it
during [ __ ] jubilee weekend yeah that
that like that looked like hell man yeah
i was filming with chris uh at um
westminster bridge and it was just like
you couldn't move yeah like it was so
busy because everyone was waiting
because it wasn't the only thing that
was happening that day was the jets and
stuff were flying yeah yeah which was
kind of cool like the jets flew over in
the formation of 70. right like a a
stupid amount of jets i'm like is this
where our military powers go okay
and then they did the [ __ ] red white
and blue not america uk uh all that
[ __ ] came over it was just crazy it
was just so busy could not get phone
signal anywhere because it was just so
many people were there it was really
cool i got a view through like a shitty
bridge because i i was stopping to try
and set up my irl bag yeah we could not
get signal anywhere to start the stream
um
but yeah because like there was just so
many people right it was cool it was
like one of those things you're like i
was actually in like the right place at
the right time to see this thing happen
yeah yeah yeah um and so i i finally
managed to find a spot like three or
four miles away from where we originally
were gonna start this yeah
where it was like okay the signal is
kind of okay yeah let's just [ __ ]
start it yeah and my laptop is in my
hotel room connected to the internet and
i press go live and it's like one
kilobyte and uh one megabyte sorry and
for twitch you need about six it can
work on three to four but it's it's
sketch yeah and i had one and i was like
[ __ ] and we already started we already
spent like an hour prepping and i was
like
[ __ ] and then i see and you know that
funny thing where when your pc is
connected to wi-fi and internet yeah for
some reason they'll be like
uh sorry uh it was connected to wi-fi
and ethernet yeah i was like i'll just
use the wi-fi yeah
i like the wi-fi it's kind of it's kind
of sick like it's wireless and it's like
no no no no use the [ __ ] why would
you use the slower one when you connect
it to the first one i'm sure there's
some [ __ ] engineer in the comments oh
actually it's because
i'll be like i don't [ __ ] care
to me it just doesn't make sense right
yeah so on my remote access with my
[ __ ] phone i'm like trying to like
zoom in click the wi-fi thing turn off
the wi-fi and then suddenly it's all
working perfectly yeah we go live and we
[ __ ] around in london it was great it
was really fun you know we you know
chris is probably the happiest i've ever
seen him in the uk bro chris seemed like
he was in his head bro he was in like
cloud9
i'm so glad to be back i just want to go
to a pod i want to have fish and chips
mashed pies i don't [ __ ] know my man
was like cleaning up english breakfast
i think he was doing like the english
breakfast tour of the uk yeah i'm gonna
try it here i'm gonna try it here i'm
gonna try it here
man was unstoppable it was great time
though it's so interesting just seeing
the dichotomy of like chris doing an irl
stream with you in japan versus in the
uk yeah in japan he's just like you know
just don't talk too loud i don't want to
be a [ __ ] yeah i feel like in japan
i have to be the one who's like yo we're
gonna do this we're gonna do this
it was just so fun
it was great it was great i didn't get
to hang out with chris before because
yeah i was like i was like stacked every
day oh yeah of course obviously i mean
yeah you have so much [ __ ] yeah yeah
then you had to like you know uh
entourage the uh the american family and
show them around and make sure they
weren't in trouble yeah yeah yeah i mean
it was it was a very very interesting
interesting experience showing them
around uh because like the first night
uh they you know they just flown in
um and
so they didn't want to go too far but we
went to like my local pub which is
literally like down the road right but
it's like so it's it's like not in like
central central brighton it's like we're
like on the outskirts of brighton
whatever so it's it's not somewhere you
see like
a lot of like touristy people go right
because brighton's like a pretty famous
touristy place uh and i remember we go
there
and
we sit down we're having a pint and
obviously they're american and they got
like the true
british experience right right it was it
was a local pub
and we had
local people there and
some
some younger people
uh recognized their accents
oh my god
were they like road men or something
yeah yeah
and i've never seen like you know you
know there's always like the image of
how americans think british people speak
and like for the first time sydney's
family got like the true british
experience right right right they they
got true local brits and i remember they
were having like they were like
there was this one kid having a
conversation with sydney's brother
and
and of course he was talking about his
[ __ ] rap career that was that was
going to take off in new w in america
because he had listeners from new york
and he had like a spotify account yeah
and i could i could see sydney's
brother's face just like i know you're
speaking english
but i have no idea what the [ __ ] you are
saying
it was literally like a scene out of the
in-betweeners right like yeah maylene's
husband marky had the exact same
experience when i like took him to a
friend's house yeah yeah yeah and like
my because my friends in london they're
not originally from london they're from
like further up north right so they have
the more northerner accent and uh and
one of my friends yusuf uh he has like a
really strong leeds accent right which
is like
hard even for me yeah yeah to understand
sometimes so it was just [ __ ]
hilarious every time uh
yusuf like opened his mouth
and just said something yeah just monkey
would just like
squint like this like he's like really
trying to [ __ ] close
he's like this is definitely english
i think
i don't know and every time yusuf would
stop talking i would turn to maki in
japanese i'd be like did you understand
that he was like no
and then he got really sad
and he was like i thought i was good at
english
but i guess i'm not and i'm like don't
worry don't worry about it it's fine
this is like this is like even i have
trouble with this thing yeah that should
be on like the toeic exam it should be
like can you understand a man from leeds
if you can you're fluent right yeah
pretty much you're good to go yeah
it's funny because like if the more
northern you go the harder time it gets
for like anyone outside of the uk to
understand what the [ __ ] is being said
exactly yeah because even for me as like
of southerner i can barely understand
what's being said in like liverpool oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah op being from
the north it's like you just understand
everyone yeah that's right i'm like yeah
super chill it's all good lucky the only
time i struggle is like i think there's
a really uh i felt ashamed at this one
point there's i think there's a clip of
a really really rural irish uh pub and
then they interviewed is that the guy
with like the three teeth i think so and
he just [ __ ] says [ __ ]
i was like even at that point i'm like i
only understood like three words it's
like the guy from kalani or something it
might be something but like that was the
only time where i'm like yeah i don't
even know if if if the other people in
the pub understood him i i don't know if
i'm the one
but the interviewer understood him
because he's from that point that's
right yeah so he was like he the guy
would just be like
and be like yes i like this pub too
you're conversing with this guy
yeah i wish i understood that anytime i
felt like inadequate i was like yeah i
thought i understood everything
everything [ __ ]
yeah i know the exact video you're
talking about as well because like i i
felt disappointed as well because i'm
like i'm like i'm sure i can understand
this i'm sure i can understand this
yeah don't know you just start uh you
you like start playing at like 4.5
speeding like maybe i can like gauge the
system
the closed captions just say [ __ ] i
don't know yeah
i don't even think the closed captioning
can determine if it's english or not i
wish it was like a tv ad one so they'd
have to have that like woman who like uh
does the uh sign language sign language
she's trying to do the shot
she's just like
i give up dude
i don't give a [ __ ]
do they have like strong accents in
whales like to the point where
maybe nothing you wouldn't be able to
understand just a very like oh i'm from
this village you know we talked about is
there like differing like geographical
differences in whales like the uk or is
it kind of just like um yeah stronger or
weaker i generally like the more north
uh
west you go uh i heard some [ __ ] do
the thing about that yeah uh it gets a
little stronger the south has a
different accent but it's not like
completely i wouldn't say it's that
different but they also have different
words yeah so i feel like the difference
is not so much in the dialect more so in
uh well not the dialect is the written
word yeah the accent isn't as different
just the words yeah so the accent sounds
very similar with both but you get the
more traditional welsh accent that you
might hear in movies and stuff from the
south yeah so
it's more of a dialect difference than a
pronunciation yeah yeah the the
dialect's pretty similar i mean it's
basically it's like translation
yeah so it's like japan yeah yeah i mean
it's because there's like the the
[ __ ] history is so uh different
between the north and the south yeah the
south was like conquered by england for
a really long time and then north wasn't
so yeah it's way more welsh up north and
then it's it's you [ __ ] know you've
watched villain saga
just like they they lightly touch it a
little bit i'm jealous because australia
doesn't have that at all and i always
thought it was really cool because like
you know american like the uk it's like
oh you can immediately tell where
someone is from yeah yeah but in
australia we don't have that at all yeah
i really love the history of it but like
no one gives a [ __ ] so it's really
boring to talk about it and i i don't
want to talk about it if people are like
they're like [ __ ] resident sleeper
they're like
it's like yeah but video is pretty good
it's a [ __ ] mess it's pretty cool
though at least you got an anime
surrounding around and right right yeah
and you got one of the most about if
you've got england but at least we had a
scholar yeah yeah yeah
you got one of the most badass
characters in all of anime man
we got is [ __ ] five minutes in a
hetalia episode
uh you got rin from free
yeah oh wow
bro he's
when i did watch the free movie and i
saw sydney station i was like yeah
let's go
i think the most representation i've had
is just like one guy from yuri on ice
and that's that's it that was that no
what about the chaon movie that was set
in the uk right now i'm talking about
thailand thailand oh thailand yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like we had a one thai
ice skater in yuri and ice and i
remember when i went to like there's
like a big anime chain in japan called
like animate yeah so we have an anime in
bangkok yeah and like they had like the
[ __ ] there were there was just like this
one cardboard cutout of that one thai
ice skater from yuri and ice i don't
know it's just like we did it boys
this is kind of lucky one of the most
badass anime characters as well that's
pretty cool yeah he's definitely up
there and not because he's well that
might have bumped him up a few weeks we
just got like racially profiled by
hetalia character
that wasn't even accurate and then he
was in one episode and he never came
back got an entire account wells didn't
even get one yeah every no every other
country got it yeah except whales
apparently whales didn't get it they
were like what are they [ __ ] doing
well
this is it again i've said i've said
this a billion times whales is a
branding problem we need a brand
the person in charge of welsh branding i
don't know who it is prime minister i
don't know we need to [ __ ] sort this
out we need to we need to have a game
plan of how we're going to brand what's
there in wells
see that's the thing what am i going to
tell you like oh do you like history
great well there's loads but if not like
go need some [ __ ] sheep that's great
if you like lamb it's amazing we also
have some pretty good baked stuff like
yeah we have a lot of welsh cakes that's
kind of good but i mean that's that's
yeah because like because like to me
like nature's yeah i've been to like
ireland and i'm like i [ __ ] love
ireland like yeah it's like one of the
most aesthetic places i've ever been to
like felix went to wales he loved it he
went to uh aberystwyth no i think it was
uh yeah yeah really cool looking place
that was inspired by like mediterranean
things yeah weirdly in like the west of
wales yeah yeah it's a really cool area
he sold me on wales yeah there's a lot
of really cool areas it's just like you
can't
like you can't drop up yeah like if you
if you just rock up without researching
where to go yeah you're gonna be like
where the f where the [ __ ] is everything
what is there to do like where am i if
you know what you're going for there's
some amazing hiking spots really
beautiful nature parks uh like a lot of
the north uh brecken beacons area is all
like nature reserves like nothing's
built there it's just just go hike
having a great time oh broken breakers
is really good yeah yeah yeah um and uh
yeah snowdonia uh snowden snow snowdonia
snowdonia so that sounds like a place
from like game of thrones yeah that's
like a pokemon series yeah i mean chris
has been up here yeah that's good uh
there's yeah there's a bunch of cool uh
seaside stuff that you can go to but
like yeah it depends yeah yeah you
really have to research because like
when you hear about people visiting the
uk obviously there is like english
islands yeah yeah and people are like oh
i [ __ ] love going to ireland because
like every [ __ ] fifth person here in
america is apparently like
like half irish or some [ __ ] right but
then you also hear people talking about
like yes scotland
i think it really helps for the uk
countries like okay you have london and
then you can branch out you have
scotland then you can branch out you've
got dublin then you can branch out it's
like you have card
even then cardiff is really far from all
the nature stuff like yeah it's kind of
weird in the u in wales where if you
want to kind of travel
via public transport up north you have
to go around and back up you don't you
don't go you can't just go through the
middle so if you go if you've got that
there's like a lot of mountains or oh
yeah there's a lot of mountains and it
didn't make sense to build the trains
there because it kind of connects
through england right and it goes back
in just like shrewsbury and stuff yeah
so if you go really far west and it's
just going on off on it's kind of really
annoying to get back up so if you're
going westward you plan your whole trip
to go west and then you go back right
it's kind of annoying to go back up like
you can if you want to go to like abba
dust with but that's no aberration is
down south we're saying no no that's a
tower there's so many fights
it's all it's all weird it's a really
cool place if you plan your trip it'll
be cool
yeah there's again there's some amazing
stuff you got to show us around because
like i've never had like a guide for
whales yes basically you have to bear in
mind my my experience with wales was
when i was like young and a kid so if
you're like a show me whales and i'm
like
you yeah but i'm going to be like that
for australia yeah yeah sure like like
my view of sydney is going to be very
different
the average tourism yeah i think because
all my tourism was done in the confines
of like school trips and stuff yeah it's
like very like warped yeah what i
actually would think would be fun my
parents know that my parents love doing
it they they like they're doing this
thing where they go all around wales
like by walking right not in one go it's
like in trips right right so they do a
section and they go back and then they
do another section and then they go back
it's cool it's [ __ ] insane
my parents love walking yeah and
exercising i wish that rubbed off on me
it's like where's the clown i've got the
bare minimum of wanting to walk and
stuff yeah but uh yeah if you if you're
interested in like really convoluted and
complex history yeah you might want to
look into it it's kind of cool yeah it's
just about people trying to not be taken
over by the english for like 400 years
and then they fail more history more
history than what we've got dude it's
pretty like pretty much every country on
in like the uk right i think they did a
pretty good job look at the rest of the
world they didn't last very long against
england i think we did pretty good uh we
had a pretty good run
but it's pretty good right sir
yeah but i mean it's cool there's some
really funny history moments of i think
i've ever told that i've told that story
before about the castle like it took
over yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then i
[ __ ] loved that story yeah it's so
[ __ ] funny i wish we had like fun
stories like that yeah like we don't we
don't know we didn't have any of that
[ __ ] yeah we're just like yeah a bunch
of convicts was just like [ __ ] you uk
and then we just started our own country
and uh yeah just a whole lot of uh
racism and politics yeah yeah it's like
it's it's like it's because
when sydney's family were visiting like
you take for granted just how much
history the uk has yeah because you
could you could show that like i i was
showing them just like even just like
seeing even them just seeing like
buildings yeah pubs that were just like
really old
that's like fast that was like
fascinating yeah many churches in the uk
have been around since uh over 1400
years yeah like there's a lot of
churches that are still like built in
eight eight hundred like this is just
insane yeah they're still there it's
crazy and it's like we take for granted
just having like a country with like
history in it whereas like i think if
you're like over 25 or something in
america then you've like been alive for
like a tenth of the entire country's
history yeah
your entire country's age and that's
like [ __ ] that just [ __ ] blows my
mind you know
that there's a country that that is that
young but then you get you run into the
issue of like okay i want to learn about
uk history where do i start and then you
go with the highlights but then when you
start digging into stuff you're like
this is really [ __ ] convoluted right
okay so they took over and then another
guy took over and then another guy took
over and then england got taken over by
vikings and then now it's the french
yeah it's convoluted but it's super
[ __ ] fascinating if you're into that
[ __ ] right that's what makes it even
cooler that all like some of these
churches and stuff have lasted like
being taken over like 10 different times
yeah right like it's like how the [ __ ]
did this it's the exact same thing with
like japanese history as well yeah yeah
and that's what makes it so fascinating
for history like fanatics right but it's
like you know [ __ ] yeah australia's not
even 250 years old yeah we [ __ ] were
founded in
1777 i think 78 yeah yeah which is like
[ __ ] like the uk had like already
figured this [ __ ] out
we were just like oh what the [ __ ] do we
do
like a lot of modern like a lot of
countries that we know today and we're
like super used to like i'm very new
yeah i think finland is only like 100
years old yeah oh germany yeah yeah like
to think that germany like was like like
a completely different [ __ ] thing
yeah like because we've been alive our
whole life i mean our whole life is like
angela merkel like it's so weird when
you're like these countries are not like
they weren't a thing yeah i don't think
germany want to talk about that yeah
they don't
yeah
actually they do talk about it a lot
they're like be ashamed
i don't know how we got onto countries
or whatever the [ __ ] but i mean i love
talking about history and countries i
[ __ ] i'm obsessed with history i love
it so much yeah and uh but there's just
too much to learn
i just that's just too much i gotta pick
an era you know like i i get so jealous
when i meet people who are like dude i
[ __ ] love the byzantine era and i'm
like [ __ ] dude that's just like i've
i've heard of that from age vampires
it's like it's like i feel like i'm a
history buff but then someone talks to
me about like ancient rome and egypt
yeah like [ __ ] i wish i had like i wish
that was the stuff i was really
interested yeah i just loved like the
past 1000 years
even though that's pushing it
i i love like the ancient stuff you know
yeah but then you feel like is your
history more better
is your history
it's like is it more significant because
like the romans yeah okay dude that's
kind of that's kind of [ __ ] sick yeah
you can't you can't go up against it
yeah yeah yeah i don't know but yeah i
mean i mean that's been this episode of
trash taste i guess hey look at all
these america yeah america let's go
let's welcome all the patrons yeah as
per usual welcome to america guys yeah
welcome
how many of them are american so like
the uk arc didn't actually last that
long we filmed three episodes but
literally like we went to the uk for a
wedding yeah uh and we somehow got three
episodes out of that which is like
pretty impressive it's probably going to
be like eight plus yeah we're gonna have
a lot more for the america yeah you're
gonna you're gonna see this set for a
while
and uh we're gonna have a lot of guests
as well so yeah very exciting guests
coming soon yeah yeah yes so yeah look
forward to that unfortunately if you're
one of the viewers that like hearing us
shoot [ __ ]
we're going to go back to that don't
worry don't worry i mean you just heard
of shoot [ __ ] now you know but we have a
rare opportunity where we can get a lot
of guests
in a very very short amount of time and
we wanted to take advantage of that uh
rather than just waiting for people to
come to [ __ ] japan which we've been
waiting for two years god knows that's
gonna happen yeah yeah yeah but uh hey
if you'd like to support the show go
over to our patreon patreon.com also
follow us on twitter send us your memes
on the subreddit and if you had our face
listen to us on spotify yeah and uh we
will see you for more la goodness i'm
sure by the end of this we're gonna have
so many american stories so many look
forward to those all right
[Music]
you